this week we've got jewel heist deadly
dog lick and facial recognition dog dick
[ __ ] weird out there dude whoa you
thought it was deadly dog dick yeah
that's what I heard Wow
our first story there these crown jewels
Swedish crown jewels that were stolen
sounds like a joke I know all crown
jewels were stolen that sounds like a
ball sack like a movie like like a
premise of like some double-oh-seven
[ __ ] or something like post-op trans
right yeah but that get weird cuz that
get weird yeah we're all Crown's of the
swedish king and queen who died in the
early 17th century dope son yeah now
that's so dope what are those wands like
the magic and she dies corpse yep
they're mad oh do people back in the day
they knew how to do it man look at that
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] dope every [ __ ]
rapper you're doing tight dude we got
that [ __ ] right there don't trip you
need a [ __ ] orb hell yeah what are
those other things that aren't wands
what are those baby was a baby that's
their pimp Cup oh yeah that's where they
keep their Hannah seed bags walk around
with the ball in a1 yeah so can you get
all the ass holy [ __ ] I want to steal it
of course how much is that [ __ ] worth
there's bazillions well they're saying
that there is their invaluable objects
of natural national interest that's so
it's worth hella money yeah why didn't
they just say that there's no the money
it's worth hella money my god I think
what the china says invaluable mean like
it's you can just infinite there's no
money that can replace it yeah
so it's worth more than a billion more
than a trillion all right that money
don't buy feelings that's what they're
trying to say true that's what they're
trying to ant dependence yeah it does I
root for bank robbers so I root for this
[ __ ] every time I see a bank robbery I'm
like go for it dude songs nobody dies
get that cash from the little chase bank
pulling $50 out of my thing when I
overdraw yeah get that money dude that's
why they got like the glasses like this
pick out their Russian chick on please
don't rob like I always take my glasses
off because they think I'm gonna rob
though I always leave like ever walk in
with sunglasses and everybody stares at
you like is today the day right yeah so
I take them off I'm like I'm here in
peace you know that's probably why heist
movies are so popular like people love
watching it it's like you could live
vicariously through the robber by
curiously back curiously bicurious story
made headlines because of the way that
it was stolen it was like a heist out of
a movie a Hollywood movie because
they're saying that's B's it's a chicken
like patent leather suit yeah Catherine
zeta-jones I'm not gonna forget that
oceans - hmm oceans - there's two people
yeah there's two guys and they're saying
that these two men they used women's
bikes to race toward a motorboat near
the bay by the cathedral and then
they've just jumped on there and they
sped off like a movie damn what's a
woman's bike can I ask some density
that's what they reported why do guys
bike had the bar high and girl's bike
had the bar low oh that's a woman's you
hit your nuts that's a woman's bike it
should be the other way around so I
don't Jack my jewels oh I think I know
why actually I think back in the day
women only wore dresses so it's really
hard to get the dress across so they
made it lower so that it was easy to get
the dressing that's a legit answer to a
weird [ __ ] ride the bike with their
legs together
that's a forest dude that was a horse
how would they paddle paddle because
they're not supposed to they're not
supposed to well they're right if
they're riding behind a man the way
they're supposed to yeah and not how -
all right to be like down on this side
yeah in the back and the [ __ ] dude
the laundry make me some egg rolls yeah
in the fact while you guys drive less
I'm telling ya it doesn't sound so bad
Oh forgive my first Agadir life yeah
won't you get in the back you're [ __ ]
relax and eat all the food while I do
the work [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah wait
great yeah no but yes event apparently
this whole manhunt and it involved a
helicopter multiple boats but there's
never been any arrests and slashes gone
yeah like they don't know oh my god I
feel like the limited like knowledge I
have of Sweden it's like really nice
there and pretty sure they just walked
in there like I'm gonna take that
they're like all right now the whole
story true well they are saying that no
one was hurt of course because they
asked for it and he gave it to him I
heard that whole area like Sweden Norway
whatever their crime rate was like super
low until like refugees came sooro I
love George Soros mmm bad boy he is you
ever see a man you kept those bags under
his eyes that's just Shady nostalgia
Soros here's the thing man
security is an illusion it's my pity
like you ever go to 7-eleven you got
that old like dude it's dirty yeah
they're like its own robbed this place
that dude ain't gonna do jack [ __ ] if I
was security guard and somebody robbed
that I would help the robber I'm like
I'm making $10 an hour why am I gonna
stop this robbery you know that gun is
just for the show yeah it's technically
only supposed to be used when the gun is
on you what do you mean so like for most
security unless they're like off-duty
cops or something like that like because
I went to go and get my guard car
wouldn't feel robbed a 7-eleven no I was
gonna do I was gonna do security and
when I was like so you can go ahead and
get your what do you call it you're
you're exposed carry it's not a
concealed carry but it's a license and
it's you get your guard card and you can
have it but you're supposed to be a
professional tattletale
so the job of a security is just to be
the designated person to report to the
police and know how to tell a story like
right so it's not really to stop people
or do anything but if a gun is on you
then you can shoot back but if the gun
or if it's on someone else like if it's
threatening someone nice then you can
shoot them but it's really like you
can't really play a cowboy and be cop
and stuff
and it's really dangerous if you do
because you could get into deep [ __ ] so
that's really for show like when you see
the guys with the guns and stuff they
can't do nothing whenever you see those
armored cars driving around you know
that's gotta be the most nerve-wracking
job could you know one day someone's
gonna take a shot at it when you're
driving around grabbing all the cash
yeah yeah one day it's gonna happen that
the only get like like 12 15 bucks an
hour yeah you risk your whole entire
life for that one really yeah well I
don't know it might be different now
because this was over ten years ago when
I wanted to do it dude if you see me
doing security just know you can rob
that place I will not stop you I know
for a fact I would quit right there quit
I'd run off I grab a Slurpee and just
head out a hundred my friends my
friend's dad is security for this
building that guy isn't protecting [ __ ]
yeah like legit I've seen him running to
a [ __ ] like light stop just before
just out of nowhere he's [ __ ] he
falls asleep all the [ __ ] time for no
[ __ ] reason there are a lot of senior
securities that I'm just like man I feel
like I need to protect you if [ __ ] goes
down memory for 9/11 all the oddly at
the airport was all senior citizens they
just gave him that job before TSA yeah
now it's all like c-minus students from
high school man who lost his hands and
his legs after he contracted a
life-threatening bacterial infection
from a dog lick watch it shows your
life's not good you don't know your nose
we lost hands and legs like all limbs so
he's that dog dude he's just uh I'll
show you photo I picture a man that's
like this with the head dogs who I was
supposed to be some of the cleanest
saliva in the world yeah anti bodies and
[ __ ] in there like it's disinfected this
dog must have [ __ ] licked some oh no
it's crazy because this bacteria is
found in healthy dogs and cats
oh and this bacteria causes severe
sepsis and fatal septic shock and
gangrene of the digits and extremity or
extremities high-grade bacterium
Mia Minden I'm not gonna let my dog lick
my wounds anymore yeah you do like that
it's like a disinfectant so it's like oh
if you don't have a hydrogen peroxide
Rock you make our dogs lick your [ __ ]
room no these guys weren't lucky enough
with the other one they did number Tyson
it's supposed to heal faster
what about neosporin and all that other
[ __ ] we've done testing proven to worse
it's not organic oh you're all about
organic dog saliva is organic got
organic as you need a [ __ ] double
cheeseburger how much is this is just a
guy that just refused to go to the
doctor like if this is a woman you get
like a weird thing you go right to the
that's true guys well I refuse to go to
doctor I refuse true guy's like hey
limbs are just like falling off it's
like okay I'll go to the doctor that's a
start that's weak guys finally go to the
doctor well they're saying that within
hours he started getting symptoms and
his body started going to something
shock Wow she went to the hot so he got
like that infection poisoning [ __ ]
within a couple hours yeah it's crazy
was it an open wound this is Greg before
that happened so he was a dog lover his
wife was saying that he'll let and he'll
just pet any dog cuz he just loves dogs
and so around it's not gonna be about am
I gonna ride motorcycles anymore back oh
he's a motorcycle over around the time
that he he got this he was near eight
dogs so they don't know which dog was
the one I was carrying but this is what
he look like oh my god his whole like
Grammy go [ __ ] the whole body like his
whole skin it looks like someone beat
him up Oh
oh no oh my god gotta cut his [ __ ]
legs off and his arms legs and his hands
dude I'm getting rid of all my dogs yeah
we gotta get rid of our dog how did they
know that it was the dogs licking for
sure I would [ __ ] hate dogs after
this I would just kill every single dog
I saw he has no arms or legs
yeah he's like super positive now he's
just like well you know what just do it
he was lying the doctors do what you
gotta do to keep me alive
he's freaking tough I don't know if I
want to live okay I still want to live
why there's still much more life to go
it's not like
you lost everything I lost everything I
literally want all my lives I've lost
every you have your dick though I would
you can't even jerk off though was he
gonna nub it you pay someone else to I
bet you you could figure it out hell
yeah get a pocket [ __ ] but just go down
a long I would be okay with losing my
limbs if like the prosthetic game was on
point right now imagine how much better
your stand-up comedy set would be
crawling up the stage like that laughing
at you already right out of pity and you
don't even have her fingers we got to
grab the mic like this that's [ __ ]
tight I hear a crazy story there used to
be an open mic or guy and they don't
know how it happened but he lost his
face and he would do stand-up and people
be like and he wouldn't even address it
he'd just like be like you ever been to
Walmart they're like what happened your
[ __ ] face I would just walk around a
Lucha Libre like every day would be
about even a part of his bit he doesn't
completely ignored no face nose down no
mouth just straight where's the sound
coming from I don't know just some
creepy [ __ ] dude down so what'd you guys
think about the 405 ha ha ha
what the [ __ ] yeah so people are just
waiting why here because like finally
explain but yeah but he never does and
it just ends never did that's crazy
well they're saying that they might even
have to cut his nose no mom I thought
like the doctors is playing pranks on
and he's like what why maybe they don't
like cannibal he just wants to eat
mystery solved that is well you always
go the doctor thinking he's like a good
dude you don't know there's gonna be
some sick and twisted doctors out there
there's a lot of those in history and
they've been alive yeah some
Frankenstein doctors out there doing
weird-ass [ __ ]
I watched American Horror Story I know
they exist all right for our last story
here
are a couple restaurants around the
country that are using facial
recognition technology to remember your
food orders oh she's actually one here
in Pasadena really what does it call
Cali burger
Cali burger that doesn't sound good that
sounds through one of those dudes that
always order something different when
you go yeah and that wouldn't be helpful
okay I never order something different
yeah me too I get the same [ __ ] at every
time I go to specific restaurants for
that specific thing same brunch spot for
me every day same [ __ ] do you ever go
there and you go this time I'm gonna do
something different and you go I don't
know when I do something different
though they even know they're like oh
switching it up today eat the same [ __ ]
you know well you ever go there and
watch people look at the menu like it's
changed yeah like you know what the
[ __ ] on the menu order you're lonely
[ __ ] no yeah I hate the people
who sit there and they just try to have
like the longest conversation of the
person and there's like a huge line you
know I mean there should be like one
lane for people who don't have friends
always old friends late - it's like man
this [ __ ] weather right nobody
[ __ ] cares move like what the [ __ ]
dude
maybe this facial recognition thing
would be good for you because they have
these kiosks then you just walk up to it
and what does it look like I don't have
a photo oh dang is it like connected to
the government [ __ ] where course it is
do they're gonna find where you are like
that 23andme well everybody sent in
their DNA that was how to collect your
DNA do the snapchat filter with
everybody doing dogs
that's just facial recognition ship for
the government dude
snapchat never made money dude it's
never made money it's always lost money
so it just keeps going keeps going it's
a database yeah for sure for shady and
[ __ ] as I see my face getting
recognition
freaking out right now right it's okay
as long as I'm sure that they're yeah
I'm not doing some secret top-level [ __ ]
don't really matter
we're drowned out within like two
hundred million people yeah but that's
not the point
see everybody says like I have nothing
to hide first of all who doesn't have
anything to hide I have a lot of [ __ ]
tonight I don't want my privacy stuff
you jerk off to that's the good stuff
man why should the government know that
do you imagine if instead of your like
your computer and your phone but people
just went in your house and just start
going through you it's the same thing
that's true it's literally like you come
home one day there's like a CIA guy
we're just going through your drawers
and oops how many [ __ ] vibrators do
you have in your [ __ ] drawer what if
they misinterpret something that they
like just logged into and then you they
use that against you for evidence or
whatever they're like [ __ ] you up
no it's until you get lippy that's what
they use it for it's like all you want
to talk [ __ ] what about this and you're
like okay I'll be quiet what about you
in these [ __ ] doggy ears here yeah
what's this in the background yeah or
whatever like right now the government
has facial recognition of every stripper
in and by the way why do women love
boomerang so much like that's like
there's always this battle between our
women funny and I think women are funny
but the boomerang feature makes me
question that cuz you just look oh look
at me look at me it's like it's not
funny it's not funny okay maybe that's
just my own war it's worth because I
guess you've seen a lot of them that's
all I see all my friends just boomerang
boomerang I can't like let's make a
boomerang video I'm like no I won't do
it
you gotta get a boomerang
no today you're doing okay you know what
my favorite one is right now is the zoom
in [ __ ] baby and in it [ __ ] goes like
that or have you seen a zoom in [ __ ] no
you just started that [ __ ] that's I do
it with my dogs all the time but zooming
[ __ ] that's why like they're like I told
them looking in the oh wow they listen
how many times you have to beat them to
get them to do just once whatever you
see animals in an amble like I interact
or in a movie you know that talk that
dogs been through some [ __ ] yeah sure
right I'm with you like that's why the
white tigers attacked uh the Siegfried
Roy they're like oh [ __ ] I remember that
did they like eat his head or something
he died yeah he puts his hands like ah
[ __ ] you you put your head in a [ __ ]
Tigers [ __ ] mouth have you seen like
those uh when [ __ ] goes wrong I like
circus and all that stuff like the
elephants and everyone just goes [ __ ]
this [ __ ] yeah yeah and they start
throwing people I'm sorry I always root
for that I was doing those uh those bull
fights when the Bulls go up into the
arena
wrecking people yeah am i swinging
around throwing people I'm like that's
[ __ ] did you see that video of their
[ __ ] Safari dude where elephant was
charging him and he just stood his
ground and elephant stopped so I guess
like elephants are highly emotionally
intelligent yeah so as long as the
person stays calm they'll read that
energy and then they'll stop obviously
it takes a very specific unique human
being to do that but that should threw
me off I'm talking about the elephant
Ryan the Elven win what's up fool I
started coming Adam and the dude in the
Safari guy just stood his ground you
just chill and the elephant stopped and
skidded like a cartoon yeah too crazy
watching he skids he's tough alphago
this dude's calm just like oh my [ __ ]
that like a certain person to understand
like how to calm themselves in that
situation yeah so maybe that cougar lady
that had the Cougar in her
Cougars Cougars aren't like that Donald
thing I think it was like certain
specific animals like emotional
intelligence kept saying that she said
her energy yeah she sent her energy she
like adjusted her she also sounds high
too though yeah sure she was playing a
drum and [ __ ] she goes I was calming the
Cougar down no the Cougar got [ __ ]
creeped out by you dude okay sometimes
yeah I'll crazy crazy oh yeah
sometimes you need that to survive like
belief is strong you know I bet you if
she was too scared she would have been
like I don't know what to do but she
didn't let that you know she didn't let
that phaser she got the drum and she'd
started [ __ ] channeling that positive
energy my pops
[Music]